now where are we with the new
indian variant i want to just go through
a lot of the data but before we get to
some of the charts and some of them do
look a little bit scary it's worth just
bearing this in mind
you know this is the context uh to bear
in mind for
when you when you hear anything about
variance of concern
it's the fact and this just shows you
the covered infection rates uh in
england's similar story in scotland's
wells northern ireland as well and right
now we are at the lowest rate that we've
been
in terms of percentage uh since early
september so the news is
really promising it's come down to very
low levels
and bear in mind the fact that any of
the shots i'm going to show you
showing kind of a rise in variance
they're happening within this really
tiny area
uh basically where um cases are very low
indeed that being said uh this variant
is
on the rise and it's worth just kind of
focusing on what we're talking about
when we say on the rise well
this shows you um what the nigerian
variant the brazilian variant i don't
have the south african variant there but
it's more or less the same picture
really very low
uh indeed in terms of its kind of
prevalence and this is just showing you
number of cases per week
uh public health england's data now
let's add on
um the indian variants and you can
probably see it's a big difference isn't
it so this is
different substantially different to
every other variant of this of covered
19 that we've seen
in the uk thus far except of course for
the kent variant you'll remember the
kemp variant which implanted it
kind of became the main variant uh in
the uk
around the kind of winter time well if
you look at that and add that on
actually i've got to kind of you know
expand the the size of this and squeeze
down the axis
um you can see that that's completely
dominant and the indian variant looks
like it's a relatively small slice
but it's rising quickly so much actually
so much so that chris whittie thinks
that it could become the dominant strain
uh in the uk why is that well it's worth
just looking
at the rate at which it's growing and
what we can do here is compare
the different growth rates of various uh
of these different variants so what
we've got is these lines are basically
they start at the moment that cases
surpassed
10. so you're kind of talking about a
relatively gradual increase for south
africa
you're talking about something that
looks pretty similar for
one of those brazilian strains p2 a lot
of talk about that strain
but now consider what's going on with
this indian variant
you saw it before slightly different
story different growth rates
substantially different
the question of course is whether this
line looks any different to what we saw
from the kent variant at the start of
the kemp varian because we're
we're basically kind of aligning these
to the moment that that variant those
variants were first detected well let's
add on
that kent variant it's a pretty similar
line for the most part
slightly under where it is but that
looks like a not dissimilar growth rate
okay and and again what we've done here
uh is
we've got an axis that isn't kind of big
enough to fit this on but if you kind of
look at where kent headed
well who knows if the indium variant
continues with this current growth rate
then you're potentially going to see it
doing that but of course that depends on
a lot of other things as well it depends
how much covert there is around it
depends how much
uh susceptibility there is and of course
it depends on the vaccination program
as well by the way you'll probably
remember when we're looking at lines
like this it's worth just looking at
them on a logarithmic chart
and if we do it that way here's how it
looks this is the logarithmic scale it's
kind of
it's better at reflecting growth rates
and again what you can see is the indian
variant
is not dissimilar in terms of growth
rate uh to that kent variant so that's
why chris whittie's talking about it
potentially uh overtaking it becoming
the dominant variant
and it could well be that there's more
uh it's more transmissible
we just don't really know how
transmissible it is and that
really is something that hopefully we'll
know a bit more about in the coming
weeks but it's so early
uh right now when i say early though
there is a question here
which is should the government have
intervened earlier
to put india on the red list and prevent
some of these cases from coming in
because what we're talking about with
this
is for the most part imported cases this
line here is the same thing it's the
indian variant basically total
of this particular variant of concern be
1.617.2 for what it's worth
uh and what you can see are domestic
cases but then you've got imported cases
travelers bringing it
into the country and what you can
probably make out is the white bit
starts first and then you can see it
transferring
through to domestic cases so first it's
people bring it into the country on
flights from
mumbai from delhi and so on and then
bringing it in and then you start to see
it seeding
domestic cases and let's not forget
there was a moment wasn't there around
early april
when a lot of people were looking at
what was going on in india and indeed
the indian subcontinent and thinking do
we maybe need restrictions here and in
early april on the 2nd of april the
government implemented restrictions
on pakistan and bangladesh so they got
added to the red list hotel quarantines
things like that
but it took all the way until the 19th
of april for india to be added to that
list and actually it wasn't until the
23rd of april
that that was implemented so you had a
long period here
uh then you had the warning then you had
an extra kind of three and a half days
where people had a chance to change
their plans and potentially fly to the
uk and a lot of that frankly a lot of
that happened
you can see it here you can see that
white bit there the rise that's that's
essentially this variant getting a
foothold and then you can see it
transferring through to the domestic
cases
as well we don't really know what
happens next but
boris johnson's saying making it clear
look when we were looking at this when
we were deciding which
countries were going to go on the red
list it was about variance and it turned
out that pakistan bangladesh had a lot
of the south africa variants so
it was about variance but here's the
thing that's not the only thing that
sage and these other committees uh
look at when they're just making these
decisions they also look at case numbers
and so what would be you know what do
things look like if you look
specifically at case numbers in these
countries well
same thing again these are just overall
case numbers it's not about the variant
okay
and this shows you case numbers in
pakistan and bangladesh and you can see
the uk
uh there as well and that was the second
of april when they were added to the red
list
so the question of course is where was
india at that stage let's add on the
indian
line well that had far more cases
even back then than pakistan and
bangladesh
and you saw what will happen next i mean
it took obviously until the 19th of
april for the government to add india to
the red list
by that stage india was kind of a day or
so from having
the biggest outbreak of covert 19
ever so bigger than anything we saw in
the u.s for instance
last year the biggest in pure number
terms
so a lot of people would look at that
would look at the last slide as well and
just ask themselves well could this have
happened
earlier and frankly we don't really know
the full rationale as to why these
decisions were taken
why was it that india was added to the
list very late but it's just worth
bearing in mind
up until the day that that announcement
happened with india added to the red
list
the government was planning to do a
trade mission uh to india that was very
impressive it's very important for his
economic policy so
some people wonder whether that might
have been part of the explanation for
why it was left so
late um but we just we don't really know
at the moment frankly
um however and this is a really
important thing to bear in mind
alongside all of the other kind of
caveats that i've made
you know what we've seen so far from the
data is quite promising when it comes to
suggesting the vaccines
are working on this we're just going to
zoom in very quickly i've shown this
shot once before but i think it's worth
just reiterating it
zoom into bolton where you're seeing the
most cases and like i say like that
first chart showed you
it's still small amounts in the grand
scheme of things 47 in the past
fortnight or so in bolton but now have a
look
at what you're seeing in terms of the
rise in actual cases there
and there's a pretty striking story
there look at this under 60s you are
seeing a big increase
in cases looking almost exponential that
curve there but now look at over 60s
and you see something else for over 60s
you're not really seeing much of a rise
at all and given those are people who
have been mostly vaccinated
that's pretty encouraging so you know
right now we don't know for sure just
how efficacious the vaccines are against
this
variant but early news and early data is
pretty promising we need to keep an eye
on this stuff
uh in the coming weeks as we do on stuff
like this
this shot i know it's not especially
kind of visually
uh palatable but this is a chart from
warwick
presented to sage and the idea behind it
was basically to say look
if this is more transmissible you're
going to start to see more
hospitalizations so the highest line
there
makes the assumption even if vaccines
work that it's 50
more transmissible and that results in a
peak in hospitalizations that's
even higher than the second wave but of
course
you know we've seen shots like this
before haven't we you probably remember
them
and a lot of the focus every time is on
those high
lines that's just unfortunately the way
it happens but that's not always a given
that it'll actually happen that way
this do you remember this one this is an
imperial chart
from the time when the easing of
lockdown was kind of announced
and the warning was that it was very
possible we're going to see a resurgence
in cases
in the coming months but here's what
actually happened have a look at those
dots the ones on the far left here's
what actually happened
because we have the data through look at
that
far from going up in line with those
kind of you know scary
lines that a lot of people actually
focused on a lot of people reported at
the time you know hospitalizations
rising really fast
actually what actually happened to
hospitalization so far
was maybe even lower than the best case
scenario
so just bear that in mind when you're
seeing scary charts and scary
prognostications
from epidemiologists nonetheless a lot
to keep an eye on in the coming weeks
so far the indian variant does seem to
be growing fast so far it does look as
exponential maybe even more so than the
kent variant
but whether we're facing those
consequences of higher hospitalizations
well it's way too early to know
and there's some encouraging evidence
but also
let's just wait and see what the data
tells us